the changes of store brought about
really helped Trump they gave journalist
permission to turn Trump into the kinds
of narratives that he they wanted to and
then that in turn led to an unbelievable
amount of free earned media for Trump
the the media this go around is trying
to do things a bit different though they
can't really help themselves but
especially in the first go around even
when he was a minor figure right and any
sort of objective if you you know any
kind of objective coverage of the Iowa
primaries or the debates or whatever
uh would Trump would have been a a
footnote um any any coverage weighted to
the probability of winning as perceived
at the time would have been sort of
minor he did and said things that
perfectly fit the narratives that
journalists in the post story era wanted
to tell and so they featured him very
prominently very early on and I think
that really contributed to his success
in 2016 and I think one of the things
Trump learned from media was from
reality TV is that there's no such thing
as bad press right